[Music]
109 today not bad especially considering
that we were 120 in palm springs on
saturday
the weather forecasters do it in
fahrenheit in america 120
is 48 celsius however you measure it
even for the desert city of palm springs
it's extreme
and it was 130 in death valley so mike
everett's been reporting record
temperatures for days
and the hottest june ever here he sees
drastic choices ahead
it's climate change pure and simple
places like this
may become uninhabitable at least in the
summertime
when you talk about the potential for
130 degree heat
for prolonged periods of time people
will just move
we'll migrate very similar to like we
did at the beginning of mankind we're
going to get away from the equators and
start inhabiting the north
you know if you're looking to invest in
real estate greenland is a great place
to look right now
for now it means adapting carlos has
shifted his work to earlier in the day
when it's at least a bit cooler living
out here in general
the people the everybody kind of has
already acclimated to it you know and if
we can't
work in this heat then we can't just
stay at home you know i mean
do you feel it's getting hotter though
definitely yeah
it feels like what the scientists warn
of more frequent and intense heat waves
has already arrived patrick and ryan
have just moved to palm springs
it does seem to be getting hotter um the
waves that we've had more recently
are much earlier in the year than
typical we won't get this hot until
around august sometimes or maybe
september and previous years
so having that and they're pro not as
prolonged like
these heat waves usually like three or
four days and now we've been getting
these high pressure
systems that that last for a week like
this current when we're in we're like
day three of nine
so it's gonna be this intense for a
while
and across the west with drought and
heat come the fires this year getting
bigger
earlier than usual there isn't a fire
season anymore
it's year round
california is a place that's led the way
in the move towards renewable energy
and its inhabitants are on the front
line when it comes to the dramatic
effects of climate change
here where they idolize the star of the
movie some like it hot
how much more will anyone be able to
stand
greg milam sky news palm springs in
california